One of my most frequently asked questions is,
where do you get all of your gorgeous dresses?
Hi all. Victoria,
late here. Self proclaimed tribewife.
They say if the shoe fits,
then wear it. So
I'm gonna be sharing with y'all my favorite milk made
inspired dresses. Triedwife approved.
This is my new favorite one.
Floral, kind of cinched waist,
white. Floral.
Perfect for summer, but honestly perfect for anytime.
And look at this dress. Loose and flowy,
cinches at the waist, compliments the bust.
Has a little tie here so you can tighten it or loosen it.
This is my favorite dress.
It is like Chef's kiss. Literally,
if I go out in this, I know everybody's head is turning.
Now here is another lovely dress.
Probably throw a sweater over it.
This is probably how I would wear it.
Super cute, but floral white.
I love it. Here's another dress.
This one is a little loud for me.
It has red even though it's white,
and it has floral. This is one that I probably won't reach for as much,
but it cinches at the waist,
loose and flowy at the bottom.
Okay, here's another dress that is truly the perfect headed me.
A very soft, feminine.
You could dress this up or dress it down.
Wear it with tennis shoes.
I like to wear heels, throw over a sweater,
and then it makes it look a little more judged up,
if you know what I mean. Very Complimenting light, floral.
That's a good dress. Okay,
last, but certainly not least,
is this a little milk made inspired dress?
I would say this is 100% triadwife approved.
It just gives you a cute little baby doll look
with the puffed up sleeves,
stitching at the waist. It just looks so pretty and girly.
Makes you just want to go in the kitchen and cook a five course meal.